today Chicago Mayor Rahm Emanuel sent
smollett letter a letter demanding that
he pay the city one hundred and thirty
thousand dollars in by the way and next
week to help cover the costs of the
police investigation into the fake
attack my recommendation is when he
writes the check in the memo section he
can put the word I'm accountable for the
whole well joining me now is Martin
freebies the vice president of the
Chicago Fraternal Order of Police all
right $130,000 that's roms bill to Jesse
is that enough no that's not enough it
would have been much better if the mayor
joined in calling for the federal
investigation we really feel strongly
that he should have done that I mean he
demanded a federal investigation of the
police department he advocated for a
consent decree that we think is
unjustified and that the Trump
administration and Jeff Sessions thought
was unjustified so we definitely think
this is worthy of an FBI investigation
Martin I want to play what you're
referring to is what mayor Emanuel said
today about basically telling Trump to
butt out watch yeah my recommendation is
the president go to opening day baseball
sit on the sidelines stay out of this
you created a toxic environment it's
almost like he had to get back in the
good graces graces of the left after his
performance the day before where he
actually sounded reasonable and really
smart on this issue now it's got to get
back to hating Trump because actually
this hate crime was really created by
Trump that's kind of implicit in what
he's saying there Martin well I mean he
said that yes and I'm not gonna disagree
with you and it like I said when when
the Obama Justice Department was running
things he was all in favor of them
coming into Chicago initiating
investigation that we didn't think was
justified based upon false assumptions
it was a kind of a ludicrous
investigation did Trump's DOJ said no
we're not going to put us in a consent
decree but he he and the state attorney
general put it in and now he he doesn't
want the Trump DOJ to
the gate would clearly it's something
that cries out for an investigation what
happened here what were the motives of
things it's unbelievable I mean this is
one of the more on unreal things that
I've ever witnessed when it comes to
criminal justice in the country and I've
been around a long time reporting on
this martin i also want to get your
response to the outrageous allegation by
small its attorney today now she has a
wild new theory about why those two
nigerian brothers were implicated in the
attack obviously you can disguise that
you could put makeup on there is
actually interestingly enough a video
you know i think police said minimal
investigation in this case it was it
took me all of five minutes to google
you know i was looking up the brothers
and one of the first videos that showed
up actually was one of their brothers in
white face doing a joker monologue with
white makeup on and so it's not it's not
implausible okay martin does she really
think you all in the chicago pd are that
dumb so now the nigerian brothers were
in white face that's the new thing
they're going with well does she really
care about the Chicago PD I mean the
rest of the country is getting a view
into the criminal justice system in
Chicago but if you're a Chicago police
officer these kinds of wild outrageous
things happen all the time you know
we've been reeling about Kim Fox for a
long time on cases we think are much
more scandalous for example the
exoneration of convicted killers what we
think are just totally baseless
arguments who go out and then file
multi-million dollar lawsuits against
the detectives who did the Kate who
investigated the case she measure being
a detective imagine being a detective in
this case you painstakingly investigated
a hate crime and now they're turning you
know they're ridiculing you they're
making a laughingstock out of the
citizens out of the police officers its
radius it's beyond outrageous but she
has an anti police mentality deep in her
bones anti police and I agree with you
on the Obama consent decrees that
handcuff police officers across this
country and by the way everyone should
know this on
Monday and we'll be covering it on
Monday on Monday there's going to be a
big police protest the police union is
going to have a protest against Kim Fox
you see the details there 69 West
Washington and it's got at 11:00 in the
morning April Fool's Day but it's not
gonna be a joke so you're gonna get a
big turnout there do you think Martin we
hope so our first vice president Pat
Murray's putting it together he's doing
a great job the members you know the
members are outraged about this case and
they're they're finally I'm happy that
that the national media is looking at it
and you know Chicago is crying I for
some really good investigative
journalism
it really is Martin thank you so much we
really appreciate your joining us and
what the Chicago PD do thank you so much
thank you so much